the drive into the mountains is long and
arduous so our day suggests we stop for
a bite along the way fortunately in
Sumatra Street food is a way of life on
almost every corner vendors [ __ ]
freshly made snacks from push carts or
whole in the ward shacks
like this one selling beaker a tea cake
made from coconut what is really good
everyone's favorite everyone's favorite
hello nicely my goodness has incredible
smell who's that cool the cinnamon works
this is pika-pika it's like a cookie
cake small cake Sarris flour and instead
of coconut and also they put some sugar
so it's almost like an Indonesian
macaroon well pretty much like that
that's a banana leaf underneath there
yes Wow come and see how they oh okay
put the pot back on and it bakes it well
that's right okay let me tell you okay
thank you my windscreen cooked let me
get the tongs oh sorry see how they okay
gotcha
how many B could you make a day mm mm mm
oh yeah not a day they make it look so
easy
they're angling up to eight beautiful
biscuits in there now I could even get
one so yeah I mean practice makes
perfect but how many coconuts do want to
screw this is like typical from this
area only I'm people normally at this
well you're having coffee in the
afternoon but having a tea tie
mm-hmm mm-hmm excellent thank you so
much yeah my apology was screw so many
up mm day want to see more from my
uncharted adventures please click here
to watch more clips